Село Демидів на перший погляд може видатися “українською Венецією.”
Тут оселилися чайки, качки, лелеки й чаплі.
Оце все мій город був. Він у воді.
Оселя пані Тетяни стоїть майже посеред озера вже чотири місяці.
Наприкінці лютого село частково затопили, щоб зупинити російський наступ.
Там же були росіяни, а там - наші. Вертольоти літали. Ми ходили дивитися на дамбу,
трохи цікаво було. І помітили, що вода прибуває в канави. Там канави є. Прибуває туди вода.
І все більше, і більше. Ми зрозуміли, що там чи відкрили, чи підірвали.
Виходиш, метрів два, і додається вода. Тут росіяни були, стріляють,
вода прибуває - ми не знали, що робити….
Ось такий вигляд село мало у квітні, після деокупації. ЗСУ підірвали дамбу,
яка відділяла річку Ірпінь від Київського водосховища. Вода звідти пішла в заплаву річки,
затопила луки й пасовища, почала прориватися через греблю між заплавою і селом.
Підтопленими опинилися близько 50 осель.
Мешканці Демидова досі живуть по сусідству з морем.
Крайні вулиці закінчуються у воді. Люди вчаться жити “на плаву”.
Не знаю, чи буде з них діло. Тут перчик насадила. Тут посіяла огірки - ще не зійшли.
Там вода виступає. - Льопає.
Віктор, сусід Тетяни, зриває підлогу в хаті, щоб хоч якось її висушити.
Його рідне село - Борки - затопили, коли створювали Київське водосховище.
Тепер чоловік намагається врятувати від води свій власноруч зведений будинок.
Я вже обігрівачем його грів-грів, наче висохло, а тільки прибираю обігрівач
- воно знов набирає.
Погріб на подвір’ї, так само як і в сусідів по вулиці, - затоплений.
Городину садити не можливо, дерева гниють. Тим не менш Віктор певен,
що підірвати дамбу було правильним рішенням.
Вони їх зупинили водою. Вони її побоялися, цю воду форсувати.
Намагалися форсувати, але їх розбивали.
Що тут було поле, можна зрозуміти за поодинокими верхівками дерев.
Ця заплава зупинила наступ окупантів, але тепер загрожує й самим жителям Демидова.
Чотири місяці тому село Демидів врятувало Київ. Нині лише ось ця дамба
завширшки в декілька метрів відділяє село від нового, ще більшого підтоплення.
Нині сам Демидів потребує порятунку.
Вода із заплави просочується через насипну греблю, просто на вулиці села.
Її намагаються відкачувати електропомпою і кількома бензиновими насосами.
Але бракує і потужності, і палива.
Відкачуємо, а вода назад прибуває. У більших обсягах. Ми не встигаємо її відкачувати.
Помпа за дві години спалює шість літрів. Одна. А як їх тут три стоїть,
то на кожні дві години, три помпи - це 18 літрів бензину.
Більше ста літрів палива треба на добу.
До того ж дамба з піску, глини і торфу, яка відділяє село від заплави, починає руйнуватися.
Два-три метри вже, мабуть, розмито.
Як ви бачите, був пологий берег, а зараз уже зробився пляж.
Крім того, через затоплені поля ґрунтові води в селі піднімаються
й просочуються на поверхню.
Подвір’я й город у Тетяни досі схожі на болото. У квітні під водою було все обійстя.
Жінка побоюється, що це може повторитися, адже помічає, що вода прибуває.
Бачите, вода до половини дійшла, як відкачували гарно. А тепер вона знову ось.
Буквально кілька днів - і вода буде в хаті. Це найстрашніше, що може бути.
І все ж Тетяна теж визнає, що затоплення села було необхідним кроком.
Ми розуміємо, що без цього ми не обійшлися б, бо треба було зберегти Київ.
Сюди вони б у будь-якому разі не пройшли б. Якби не було цієї води,
вони би були вже, на жаль, у Києві. Розуміємо все, але ж допоможіть нам тепер.
І місцева влада, і керівництво Київської військово-цивільної адміністрації запевняють,
що контролюють ситуацію. За словами очільника Димерської громади,
проблему вирішить ремонт шлюзу на підірваній дамбі.
За планом, роботи мають звершитися до кінця липня. Це дозволить зменшити
рівень води в заплаві, де розлилася річка.
Нами було знайдено підрядника, який виконує ремонтні роботи,
забезпечено підвіз питної води тричі на тиждень. Так само передаємо пальне
на відкачування води на місцевих локаціях. Рівень ґрунтових вод
уже сягнув того рівня, що природньо, ну ви розумієте, один із законів фізики,
тобто рівень загальний піднявся, так само і там, де проживають люди.
Те, що стосується рівня загального води - відмітка, яка встановлена,
нижче бути не може за позицією міністерства оборони.
Тим часом пані Тетяна з Демидова розповідає, як бачила лебедів у себе на городі.
На озеро під будинком вона дивиться з острахом.
Вода підходить. І, наприклад, якщо знову повернеться та вода, що робити?
І з коровами, з усім? Я вже не знаю, як там будинок. І будинок так само…
Куди його йти? Я не знаю…
Жителі Демидова сподіваються, що до зими вода відступить.
Інакше вона забере те, що не змогли знищити снаряди.